maybe a fleet Soviet you good Jan this
is the swordplay do you ever wish you
could get a little more in the way of a
brutal killing action going on I'm
swimming to win just backstage about her
fight I'm a massive rock way that moving
and there's a point drop point briefly
is a fantastic swordplay smoke was
really two swords when I was in my
twenties so as migrant did get a bit
frustrated run it most artists but she
proven to have other weapons
mr. park that snack as the game of
Thrones
my name is Gerald and I'm here
representing the Hall H posse my
question is for mr. Martin and the cast
mr. Martin you populated the world of
Westeros with many unique wonderful and
terrifying people when writing about the
characters has trials and tribulations
of the characters has that helped you
discover something about yourself or
help you overcome a real-life challenge
if so can you share that with your fans
and to the cast which cast in the show
is most like you yeah that's a lot of
questions you know you're drawing
yourself interviewing characters you may
snow on people you know on figures from
history on your imaginations but
ultimately to make that character come
alive when you're right beside them you
have to delve into yourself fortunately
you know I'm mark I think a multitude of
this I think will covet said always
still my best so a lot of different
characters and people from inside one
and I'm different from many characters
I've never been a an exiled princess or
war for an eight-year-old girl but I
think the common humanity
so these characters and we all know
about that confidence when I try to draw
be encouraged
I used to the mystery tourists or sunny
European
yeah because it seems like there are
echoes of Allah you begin to the wall
and a lot of it the way that the world
has been together is very like you know
from I guess he'll be European on is it
something that fascinated you a lot of
problems are stolen from your Scottish
history money and dispiriting history
that you have there my question is from
Rosa kid what do you think was going off
in the heads of your characters when
they saw each other again at the Battle
of the world that's a great question and
I'm really an outfit I know I think it
was an important moment for us I think
it was a I think what was only the drug
captures they used to spread happy to
see her again
really at the heart at the heart of it I
don't think this happened he is a really
care in some ways about marrow is least
he died he got to see her one last time
and I think that that moment let's see
broken with what happens next but I am
yeah I think it's a useful and it's
quite profound silence as a silence they
won't be wanted together thanks man
it was very true I mean I think that
there was that silence talking about
that it became very profound and I think
certainly for ego throughout season four
you know she was she was on the ruthless
mission and she was getting at her head
back
I don't know and I don't think she at
all anticipated just how much she loved
him and just that hesitation seeing him
get completely through at MPT forceful
that all little thoughts that was you
know mouth and awesome breath as a while
but it was very and we didn't really
want to discuss much about it on the
daily only shortage because just wanted
to see how it would
my question is for Dan and Dave mellotts
Spanish has arrived at the wall we look
for scenes developing this character for
Spanish demands I think we can say we
say yes oh yeah yes we can say yes you
can fascinating character has amazingly
well drawn by Stephen d'Alene and we
will be taking advantage of both the
character and the actor in the seasons
I'd be careful about that woman is with
him though just what are you cheers her
moments she worries me
so the question safe experience 3 in its
true form and is kind of a loaded one
you know I've said a couple friends of
those thrill how many children does for
a little paragraph Scarlett O'Hara has
three children in murdering Mitchell's
novel scholar owner and has one trial in
the classic movie of Donald wind how
many children mr. Lloyd over half was
the true story of course the true story
his father has no children she never
existed
character and their two wonderful
classic ways of telling the story and
you know that maybe the situation that
is the situation with the show is the
show and the book is the book you know
who did Robb Stark mary did you marry
that he she marry a noblewoman from
volantis named ELISA who died at the red
wedding her that she married did he
marry a woman in Jeyne Westerling who's
still alive and will be seen in the
prologue of wizard winter
you know we shoot my very first day on
set is the scene with Tyrion it was you
know my big scene and I was it was my
first thing I said is my first day in
full costume and I don't know how I got
to be honest with you it was
nerve-racking but peer made it really
easy analogous the director took care of
me but he was and from that point I mean
it sort of like just diving in right of
the gate and and that was my that was my
intro to the season and then we were all
over the place the fight sequence came a
little towards the end
so that that helps a little bit because
thank you so he is well I was looking I
think my musti's we're like velocities
all things include Seva
the fight was opposite ends club network
was busy and she knew what was going on
because I get very confused
whatever you decide your story that you
should did that seem towards the end of
in upset because they my final day ever
on the show was the time what was the
see my kids and so luckily since most
super-special seminars to ask women
would like to fight the house around and
so probably doesn't feel that
thank you stop everything your knees so
when you were trolling in that one move
I can see our right patron answer but
with Stoke you see we do like to see
anything I say right now is being
listened to by the man at that end of
the table so I'm going to shut up and
not say
be loyal to my story loves my my
compadre
all right I know that the dragons are
easy to work with and they do you tell
so obviously the poke and the show boys
go ahead in here but there was a major
character reveal that sort of happens at
the end of books three and I was just
wondering violation of the rules
been deceiving with the facade of her
former self for so long and it was such
a relief for me to finally be able to
like shed the skin and become this
somewhat manipulator that she actually
is me you know
highway that she finally it's
revealed itself it was freakin George
well it was a great scene you know that
they didn't have any other writers Brian
Collins maybe only deserves a lot of
credit who added some scenes that are
not in the book in part because they're
know people American president in every
season that I loved the first season the
scene between Robert and Cersei where
they discussed her marriage on in the
most of every scene second season in the
black works of the wonderful scene and
bran from sound and the brothel terrific
scene and I put this the of the battle
in the same innocent category it was
just afraid coming and and it was it was
terrific to watch you know the things
like Warren and for the most part that
seems that didn't make it you know I've
been pretty old missus before season one
that was we had three more episodes of
season
kill them and then I realized a quad it
would give us power in some other
Egyptian named muscle
with each other
there my question is for Maisie our that
has had to change her identity to
survive so many times it's like she's
finally on her own you know
but in the show when Jamie releases
Tyrion um it's not a short scene but in
the book really change the relationship
reasons
you don't have access to the characters
mine so there's an amazing relation
there's an amazing backstory for curium
you learn about basically inside periods
skull and we have pages and pages in
orbit learn exactly what happened and
it's a really powerful moment of the
story problem is the only way for us to
do it in the show would be either for
dialogue or action the flashbacks
showing that saying we have many
flashbacks yeah
and we didn't have voiceover so unless
we have a long scene with dialogue
explaining what happened all those years
ago which just felt like it wasn't gonna
work that was something that went both
of a second pair all sorts of these
these cuts that are currently in the
book course because oftentimes we never
reason it just doesn't seem to work on
screen when we've got 500 40 minutes to
tell and just you know this kind of goes
in it all before price episodes believe
us from a storytelling point of view we
loved after camp so they'll be fantastic
the problem is the problem is can we
actually finish post-production and
Maurice or no close-ups on the next
season absolutely no downtime between
the end of one season started nuts this
is no time for us to shoot more episodes
and maintain the kind of quality in
terms of production value going all the
different countries in those locations
having the visual effects guyscraper
dragons all that stuff so unless we find
some really big divorce lawyers
Viator I speak from some experience we
need to the I think that's a mentorship
before setting us one but one of the
things that we always hope is that
people who have watched the show that
might be drawn to the books which we
think this is true for a lot of people
and then they can learn a lot more about
the starkness of Everwood watching the
show alone and then get much more depth
and time as well discovers and learn all
about them so unfortunately as as far as
we try we can't possibly match the the
amount of detail and storytelling and
the 12 education book the course of the
season and I guess the last thing I
would say is that when we first talked
to George when we first got the books
they were sent to us to adapt this
feature films and yet it was that each
quote would be one feature so if you can
imagine that Game of Thrones is a two
half-hour movie just think about
everything that would have been that
would have been mutilated in kind of
that story and one of the reasons we
really wanted to do this as a show and
about the leaves were through those was
even though we could have everything 10
hours 20 hours and even then you know /
amazed to find out how much of the
detail we just can't get in there I
think it was I think it was Jim Thompson
the great crime novelist who reporter
asked him how do you feel about what
Hollywood has done to your books he
pointed to his bookshelf and he said
Holly was right there is there always
gonna be their own Christine bats world
books existed the law does exist the
show existed and below was existed thank
you so much and you guys are showing up
and to you guys as a Tony's favorite
Ubuntu thank you so much for coming to
San Diego thank you